says we want to find out all the
differences between Cadbury chocolates
in the UK and in India this is food Wars
Cadbury dairy milk in India comes in
ranges of four sizes number one is
Cadbury dairy milk minis it comes in
this large packet with 18 smaller pieces
of 7 grams each a smallest of these
bite-sized 11 gram bars then we have
these 18 gram little bars a simple 24
grams tiny one next up we have our
multi-pack bars which weigh 33.5 grams
the standard individual Dairy Milk Bar
weighs 45 grams your Duo bar which comes
in two halves and weighs 54.4 grams then
a 55 grams Maha pack next up we have
this 110 gram bar family pack 126 grams
then we move to a 180 gram bar we have
this 360 gram bar
the biggest size you'll find in the UK
is an 850 gram giant bar
so in India Cadbury is really well known
for its gift boxes in fact they've done
so much marketing over so many years
that it's become synonymous with
festivals like Diwali dasera and even
Christmas and New Year's on their
website right now you can get anything
from an anniversary 10 box to a Ramadan
tin box and they come in several
different sizes for starters there's a
standard personalized gift box which
contains six Cadbury dairy milk bars
three of which are silk and three of
which are standard and that's the one we
have right here in fact they've put my
face on it I mean that's a whole lot of
packaging for normal bars of chocolate
you can just buy I guess it even says
food was oh it says US versus India
sorry Harry apart from this you can also
get a larger personalized birthday gift
box which will contain 450 grams silk
bars three birthday whistles a large
Banner a birthday hat so the next time
you don't know what to do for your
birthday just order this to your house
and you can have a party by yourself now
we have some gift box items of our own
but they usually come more in the form
of of selection boxes these are most
commonly seen around Christmas time at
which point cadburys will release Heroes
and Roses which are selection boxes
containing 600 grams of individually
wrapped chocolates it's a real tradition
in British households to have a few of
these lying around the other options
include quality Street and celebrations
people tend to have their own favorites
when it comes to the selection boxes and
also the chocolates inside them I think
generally Heroes would be my preferred
option over roses I prefer the kind of
more mainstream chocolate bars that
you'll find including little whisper
bites which I think might be my favorite
if you want a gift option for all year
round up for a milk tray these have been
around for decades I think my mum used
to be giving these to people when she
was growing up and for the run-up to
Christmas you've got to get yourself an
advent calendar I don't think I'd
normally go for one of these these are a
little bit flimsy quite narrow but still
you get a lot of Joy from opening a tiny
bite of chocolate every morning and then
run up to Christmas
here are all the Cadbury products that
you'll find in India that you will not
find in the UK here are all the Cadbury
products from the UK that you won't find
in India this is so much chocolate in
terms of our classic dairy milk flavors
we have two exclusives number one roast
almond and number two crackle this used
to be my favorite as a child but right
now I really like this delicious chunks
of roast almond we have some exclusive
dairy milk flavors of our own firstly
for the health conscious among us we
have this 30 less sugar dairy milk I
guess this could be helpful as well if
you find regular milk chocolate too
sweet which some people do but then I
guess just opt for some dark chocolate
instead next up we have Cadbury caramel
it's a bar of dairy milk but inside each
square there's a little bit of caramel
this is one of my favorite ones it does
get a little bit sickly if you eat too
much of it because of the amount of
sugar but very tasty we have some big
taste bars which are chunky versions of
dairy milk starting with peanut caramel
crisp we also have a triple choc
sensation big Taste Bar which combines
dark milk and white chocolate in one
delicious bar these ones look really
cool all they've definitely put a bit
more thought into the design of the bars
tastes really good as well
next up we've got dairy milk with
crunchy bits now this is crunchy with an
ie not crunchy with a Y crunchy with an
ie is actually a bar of chalk that you
can get here in the UK it's milk
chocolate with a honeycomb Center then
we have a Dairy Milk dime bar
dime is another chocolate bar which
dairy milk has kind of collabed with I
think it's like a very thin brittle
almond caramel bar with a little bit of
chocolate on the outside my granddad
released the light down then we have
this marvelous Creations jelly popping
candy bar as the name suggests it's a
bar of chocolate which contains some
popping candy as well as I think jelly
beans I've not tried this in a long time
I want to see what the ratios are like
and also if I can really feel the
popping candy you can see like a couple
of bits of I assume jelly beans peeking
out the top the pattern is kind of odd
usually obviously you have squares makes
it nice and easy to break apart and
share I'm just going to bite into it
like a madman
you really do get the popping candy my
mouth is popping
but it's actually not too bad you get
little chewy Sweet bits in with your
chocolate there's a lot going on but I
don't hate it for vegans in the UK
Cadbury's also has a plant-based bar
I've never tried this so I want to see
if I can taste the difference between
this and dairy milk
it looks like chocolate
definitely does Taste of almond which is
okay because I quite like kind of nut
and chocolate as a combination if I went
vegan I don't know if I'd be rushing to
the store to buy this it's okay the
texture is pretty good but the flavor
just really isn't there I'll ask through
exclusive dairy milk bars are actually a
mystery two bars which contain fillings
of a mystery flavor you try and guess
what the flavor is and then you can
submit your answer online myself and the
rest of the crew have now got to try
these and give our best guesses mystery
Bob one of course last time I threw
stuff at you it didn't go very well
got it oh okay it's fruity currently
we're thinking maybe Rose I'm personally
thinking apricot struggling to agree
here we can't taste more
fruit while we figure that one out we'll
try Mystery by number two now this one
smells aggressively fruity catch Leon
I'm getting quite a lot of like very
artificial raspberry flavor I'd be
fairly confident in a certain amount of
raspberry it might be blueberry plot
twist they've already revealed the
flavors we didn't know first one was
rhubarb and custard classic British
dessert didn't really get very close to
that one second was blue raspberry which
we actually did kind of get I personally
don't think I would buy either of those
again though maybe the first one you
don't mind it and now for our silk range
or as Cadbury is trying to rebranded the
S range what is this some sort of new
iPhone but whether you call it silk or S
I love these chocolates first off we
have the typical silk basically it's
just dairy milk but a lot of silkier
then we have dairy milk silk bubbly it's
dairy milk silk but bubbly yes nice
light Airy next you have a Dairy Milk
silk fruit and nut then we have dairy
milk silk hazelnut wow there are some
proper large chunks of hazelnut the
hazelnut itself the flavor of it really
lends to the chocolate and it doesn't
taste as sweet next up we have dairy
milk silk roast installment we have
dairy milk silk moose they've tried to
recreate the flavor of mousse and you
can see that it's a lot more fudgy the
chocolate inside it's all right oh man
there's one that I'm scared to try dairy
milk silk bubbly bubble gum oh no I saw
the color of it oh my God why have they
done this growing up we had a bubble gum
called Boomer which is now what we have
all become that one bite was really not
that bad it definitely tastes like
bubble gum and gave me that Boomer Vibe
that's as much as I can have of that now
to cleanse the parrot silk Oreo um
that is a nice flavor dude I think it's
my favorite out of a lot we also have
another variation of Oreo it's a red
velvet Oreo if you've watched previous
episodes of food was you remember that
one of the ingredients that has taken
India by storm in the past few decades
is red velvet and I have tasted this
before and I actually think it's really
good but it is overkill it's literally
dairy milk silk the Oreo white cream and
chunks of Oreo that have been turned
into red velvet
you have a treadmill finally we have
dairy milk silk heart blush I imagine
you give this to your loved one it says
pull over here and I'm pretty excited
for this
Never Gonna Give You Up Never Gonna Let
You Down
I can't believe I've been rickrolled in
my own video at the back there is a very
elaborate looking tear tab so I'm just
gonna ah
not very easy to wait what
I'd probably break up with whoever gave
me this at this point this is
frustrating it's more Packaging all
right
more packaging this is honestly a very
wasteful way to tell somebody you like
them there you go it's some pink
chocolate oh my God I swear to God if
it's the same as the bubble gum I'm
gonna cry
it's not bubble gum so
this is actually quite a fun experience
I'm not gonna like
silk bars but we do have something
called Dark milk calories has kind of
invented this hybrid milk and dark
chocolate for someone whose tastes like
somewhere between those two here is the
dark milk dark milk also comes in
variations including a salted caramel
flavor and a hazelnut flavor I feel like
they've tried to Market these a little
bit more at adults maybe as opposed to
kids the packaging kind of gives a
slightly more sophisticated vibe sexy if
you will at the other end of the scale
we have some even sweeter options than
classic milk chocolate firstly we have
Cara milk which is golden caramel
chocolate this one I have not tried I'm
kind of intrigued I'm gonna have a bite
I worry it's going to be far too sweet
wow that's very sweet you do get notes
of caramel but I really don't think I
could eat more than a couple of bites of
that and of course we also just have
white chocolate as I've said I'm not
really a big fan of white chocolate and
I don't think I'm alone in that because
this basically wasn't available in any
of the big supermarkets that I looked in
the shop we were able to track it down
in was poundland which is a shop in the
UK where everything costs a pound I know
it sounds ridiculous to an American
audience but that is what it's called
you can find Cadbury boneville dark
chocolate in both the UK and in India
but there's a slight difference in the
UK the packaging is bright red and over
here we have different flavors 50 dark
chocolate and 70 dark chocolate I have
uh over the years grown to like dark
chocolate I was never a fan of it
growing up but 70 dark chocolate I don't
know oh
you know it's not as bitter as I
expected very creamy also the cocoa is
100 sustainably sourced next up we have
a fruit and nut it's got a peanut in
there
it doesn't taste as heavy as the other
chocolates I've had so far and I really
appreciate this am I growing old is that
what's happening and the final flavor is
cranberry which have been the most
excited about I don't think I've had any
chocolate bars that have had cranberry
in them but obviously cranberry and dark
chocolate sounds like an amazing
combination that is so good the tartness
of the cranberry and like the slight
sugeriness really complements the dark
chocolate it's a crunch of roasted
almond is it a winner really nice I like
this range of bone Wheels feels like a
healthier guilty pleasure we also have
some boneville products you'll find in
the UK that you won't find in India
firstly we have bourneville of Jamaica
the old Jamaica refers to rum and raisin
flavors added to the dark chocolate and
we also have an orange bourneville I
personally don't love dark chocolate and
I especially do not love dark chocolate
combined with fruit so I'm respectfully
not going to try any of these if you're
wondering where the name bournville
comes from it's actually a village that
was created by the Cadbury family for
workers who worked in the factory near
Birmingham Bonville still exists today
so you can go visit it it's home to
Cadbury World which is a kind of Cadbury
Museum interactive experience thing and
apparently is a really nice place to
live and now it's time for all of the
remaining Indian Cadbury products
starting with Cadbury
fuse
their tagline for this is a delicious
chocolatey Feast like some sort of
chocolatey mousse in the middle
surrounded by caramel and then the outer
layer of chocolate has peanuts in it so
I can imagine this being a proper Feast
kind of nice I think I could eat this
much of one chocolate but the fact that
I'm eating so many varieties of
chocolate one after the other is really
doing something to my brain like why are
we doing this no like what is this why
are we tasting all of this what is the
point of this show next in line we have
the Cadbury
crispello I want to be on the team that
gets to name all of these chocolates
seems like you can just get away with
anything it's clearly filled with some
rice krispies and things that are
Crispies hey this one is actually really
um next up
Cadbury 5 Star 3D if you don't know what
5 star is it's basically the chocolate
that made caramel cool in India it's
been around for decades and actually fun
fact it's my mom's favorite chocolate
now they've upgraded to Five Star 3D
what's the difference between this and
any other five star it has nuts I will
say having eaten the past three
chocolates in a row I'm starting to
realize they're kind of the same thing
it's decent I prefer the original five
star that one Sparks Nostalgia this one
just feels too modern next up we have a
perk so perk is another chocolate that's
been around in India for ages now and
it's gone through a lot of Evolutions
like every other chocolate has now they
sell pork in a double pack it says you
can rip it share it
oh next up some gemstones that's right
the UK didn't give us our gemstones back
but they definitely gave us gems
yeah I mean fair enough sorry guys so
they're M M's without the m m branding
on top what I used to as a kid you'd get
a small packet of gems and I would suck
on each gym until the color would come
off and it would be a white gem then I'd
put all the white ones in my mouth and
bite them like one big chocolate that
was weird and I had no friends Cadbury
Temptations rum and raise rum and uh
Cadbury Cadbury
Cadbury Temptations almond treat it
smells like rum
whoa I did not expect that flavor to be
so strong can they sell this to Children
it kind of tastes like a Christmas rum
cake yeah I don't mind it I think this
could be a great Christmas
sort of chocolate to have around next up
is my favorite childhood chocolate
nutties I freaking love nutties and my
favorite part about nutties is that The
Branding has not really changed for like
decades now what this chocolate is is
basically Cadbury chocolate coated over
a cashew nut that's covered in nubit
oh my God that is so good then we have a
load more Cadbury exclusives in the UK
and we'll start with the bars we'll
start with what is technically a Cadbury
product but initially was not this is
the fries chocolate cream bar it's a
dark chocolate bar with a creamy smooth
fondant Center a fun fact is that the
fries were a Quaker family who were the
first ones to actually commercially
produce chocolate bars in the UK before
the fries came along drinking chocolate
was kind of the only way to consume it
fries also makes a peppermint cream bar
as well as Turkish delight I will say
this is not the best Turkish delight out
there if you want Turkish delight go to
a grocery store that sells Turkish food
get some classic stuff whereas this is a
kind of slightly cheapy Turkish delight
encased in chocolate next up we have
Boost bars these are chocolate bars
filled with caramel and biscuit pieces
when boost was first launched I think
they were kind of marketed as almost
like an energy bar they had loads of
sugar and glucose in them although I
think they have now recently dropped
that down and it's just in line more
with a standard chocolate bar then we're
on two Chomps I personally love a chump
these were also a little bit hard to
find I think we have to go to poundland
for these ones as well but they used to
cost like 10p from your local news
agents it's just like a chocolate bar
with toffee caramel inside simple but
effective then we have crunchy bars
which are chocolate bars with a large
honeycomb Center personally don't love
crunchy bars I don't love the texture of
the honeycomb and they're very very
sweet what I do love however is a curly
whirly these are brilliantly named they
come in these little individual bars
like this they look a bit weird it's
kind of a web of chocolate and caramel
I used to have braces as a kid and I
really missed toffee and caramel while I
had them on moving on we have a double
decker bar a nod to the British double
decker buses this is a two layered
chocolate bar with a nugar layer as well
as a kind of crunchy pieces and caramel
layer I like these next up we have fudge
bars we've got these little bite-sized
ones today I like these the guys seem to
disagree with me but I think these are
good I will opt for these in a Heroes
box it's just a bar of fudge covered
with chocolate then we move on to the
picnic bar it's a chocolate bar that
contains I think caramel some rice
crispy kind of pieces as well as some
raisins and peanuts now while India has
a Five Star Bar in the UK we just have a
Star Bar I don't think I've ever had one
of these before apparently it's milk
chocolate with caramel and peanut let's
give it a try
that might get added to my rotation you
know that's pretty good next up we have
the 12. these are like ribboned
chocolate bars which are then kind of
cased within more chocolate it leads to
uh quite an interesting texture and
quite a nice taste the only issue with
Twirls is that they do crumble and kind
of go everywhere you can also get 12s in
orange flavor then we're on to whisper
bars I don't really know how they make
these because it's milk chocolate but
it's like aerated there's kind of little
holes all the way through it we put a
man on the moon and we aerated a
chocolate bar the result is a really
nice texture actually it sort of melts
in your mouth when you eat it I have
some American colleagues in the US last
time I visited this was the one thing
they asked me to bring over you can also
get whisper gold bars these are the same
as regular Whispers but they have a
layer of caramel running along the top
and the last but by no means least bar
is the Fredo it's basically just a tiny
piece of solid milk chocolate in the
shape of Fredo the Frog but for people
of a certain generation namely mine
they're also a surprising representation
of economic inflation to put on my angry
old man hat for a second when I was a
youngin these were 10p and then around
2005 prices started to gradually creep
up before we knew it prices were as high
as 30p for alfredo these outrageous
prices actually led to public outcry so
much so that they back down and I think
nowadays they're around 25 people the
bank of England says that it should have
been around 17 or 18p by now whereas we
are getting charged 25 so cadburys give
us some cheap photos again economic rant
is now over you can also get photos in a
caramel flavor the last thing to add to
the chocolate bars is that you can get
pretty much all of them in the form of
these share bags they basically just
condense them into bite-sized pieces and
put them in a bag that you can open and
reseal next up we have dairy milk bites
there are two flavors that we have right
now Hazelnut and almond they look pretty
similar to the silk of these flavors so
I imagine these are just smaller
bite-sized versions next up lickables
why have they done this thoughts on this
this is clearly for small children
somebody want to help me I have no idea
how to open this this feels like one of
those puzzles
oh
the lower half of it was the chocolate
and the rest of it had this toy now to
the chocolate there's a QR code because
most children have phones that they can
scan this with oh looks like goopy
Cadbury chocolate with chunks of Oreo
and you just gotta
lick it
this is this weird Cadbury okay next up
we have Cadbury chocolate bakes chalk
filled cookies in case you didn't think
this contained chocolate they reminded
you eight times in The Branding the
packaging and the design feels a lot
more premium feel like there's a good
value for money here because it was
filled to the literal brim now we're
gonna go to this side we have Oreo
dipped in Cadbury damn I'm really
enjoying this whole Oreo Cadbury
marriage over here now we have an Oreo
biscuit coated in Cadbury chocolate the
Oreo biscuits are kind of overpowering
so it's all right next up we have this
tin can of Rich dry fruits again in the
Cadbury celebrations line in India
common gifting cultures to give a box of
dry fruits and nuts and so Cadbury is
adapted really well to that okay so the
next thing is something very different
this is actually born Vita or Cadbury
bournvita and this is a drinking
chocolate we drink a lot of milk here in
India and as kids everybody who's
addicted to one of many different
drinking chocolates horlicks comp plan
I'm a Milo guy myself there was boost
and then obviously born Vita I think
most people were not born Vita people
this is Cadbury's range of
choco melts and it's a small dish of
chocolate that's used for baking and
finally the last three packets are
toffees that Cadbury sells in bulk this
one is five star bites it's similar to
the dairy milk minis from Indian fans
the five star out there comment and let
me know whether you're more of a rummies
guy or a Suresh guy these are packs of
toffees eclairs to be specific this one
is chocolate flavored and this one is
coffee flavor another quirky thing about
India is sometimes when you go to the
local stores and you pay in cash and
they have to give you change but they
don't have any they'll just give you one
of these chocolates and you can't really
argue it you just grab it and go I think
it's very cute actually it's a very
endearing thing about India but remember
if you're gonna take a chocolate from a
store screw all this take Melody Melody
is the best chocolate all right in the
UK capris offers a lot of seasonal
products now we're recording this
episode in late October so unfortunately
we can't get some of the most famous
ones what I'm of course referring to
here are Cadbury Creme eggs and Cadbury
Mini Eggs in the UK these are only
available in the run-up to the east
holidays but while they are available
they're wildly popular although I will
say I don't like cream eggs I take stick
for this I think they're gross the
fondant in the middle is grim you have
to kind of like tongue it out it's just
really bizarre many eggs however are
delicious I don't know what they're
putting in the shells of those things
but God they're amazing well we can't
get the Easter exclusives right now what
we do have are Halloween and Christmas
options for Halloween I was able to find
these goo heads I think these are kind
of a Halloween version of cream eggs so
I'm going to crack One open and see that
does look exactly the same as a Cream
Egg even down to the patterning that's
kind of printed on the egg I mean yeah
that's pretty much just a Cream Egg
I just don't like them then for
Christmas exclusives I found these
Cadbury puds these are dairy milk
chocolate balls with a truffle Center
hazelnut pieces and rice crisps they
sound pretty good we also found Cadbury
Mini snowballs which are milk chocolate
and a crisp sugar shell they might hurt
a little bit more than a normal snowball
fight if you have one of these thrown at
your head and of course you can get a
Dairy Milk Advent calendar for Christmas
it looks like some kind of mud monster
moving away from seasonal items we have
Cadbury eclairs Cadbury eclairs are
quite tough pieces of toffee with some
chocolate in the center they're a pretty
good jaw workout but I do quite like
these and another iconic Cadbury item is
buttons these are bags of discs of dairy
milk chocolate real classic these have
been around for years from there we're
moving on to Cadbury's biscuit options
possibly the most iconic of which are
fingers these are thin sticks of sweet
biscuit covered in dairy milk chocolate
they're very tasty they're pretty
Moorish and they come in these kind of
iconic sleeve tray things
I know with Joe we have a caffeine meter
but if I had a sugar meter
we're blasting off right now we also
have some other flavor options including
mint orange bornville dark and finally
white roundies are circular layered
wafer biscuits covered in dairy milk
chocolate if you're a fan of Wafers you
can also get time out wafer bars again
it's Chocolate Wafers layered and
surrounded by chocolate but this time in
more of a bar form than a circular
Biscuit the next Cadbury biscuits option
is animals Fredo has hopped into the
jungle to join his friends he's a little
animal shaped biscuits which on one side
are covered with chocolate I don't think
I've eaten one of these as an adult but
they were an excellent lunchbox Edition
when I was a little kid I'd also be
remiss not to talk about mini rolls
these are an iconic British snack what
it is is like a chocolate sponge with
this kind of cream swirl in the middle
surrounded by milk chocolate I'm not
sure why the mini roll is currently
saying I'm rich and famous but good for
the mini roll these are great finally
Cadbury's offers some baked options
which you might find in the bakery
section of your local supermarket these
can include things like donuts and
muffins but the ones I was able to find
today were Flapjack bites in the UK when
we say Flapjacks we don't mean pancakes
which I think Americans can say
sometimes Flapjacks over here are kind
of like oats held together with honey
the golden syrup and some other stuff
and these mini cookies
here's everything in a bar of dairy milk
chocolate in the UK here's everything
you'll find in a bar of dairy milk
chocolate here in India so the list of
ingredients is pretty much the same in
the UK and in India but the UK uses palm
and sheer fats which is not specifically
listed here in India India goes into a
little bit more detail on the flavorings
used in the chocolate listing natural
vanilla as well as artificial ethyl
vanilla as the name suggests this is the
main component of vanilla bean extract
some kind of vanilla is likely present
in the UK chocolate it's just contained
within the flavorings on the list but
how much chocolate are you actually
getting in your chocolate the food
safety and standards authority of India
has some minimum requirements for what
milk chocolate should contain the rules
are 25 total fat 2 milk fat 2.5 cocoa
solids and 10.5 percent milk solids we
have equivalent rules here in the UK the
cocoa and chocolate products regulations
of 2003 set the minimums for milk
chocolate at 25 total fat 5 milk fat 20
dry cocoa solids 2.5 dry non-fat cocoa
solids and 20 dry milk solids Cadbury in
the UK says its chocolate contains 23
milk solids and meets the EU minimum of
20 for Cocoa salads India's Cadbury
packaging says it contains over 22 milk
solids so thank you Cadbury for not
being chindi it is interesting that
Indian rules do not have a minimum for
dry fat free cocoa solids in milk
chocolate the dark chocolates however
have a minimum and it's 14 dry cocoa
solids tends to refer to cocoa powder
which is one of the purest forms of
cocoa having more cocoa solids therefore
gives the end products a stronger
chocolate taste
100 grams of dairy milk in the UK
contains the following 100 grams of
dairy milk in India contains the
calories are actually identical the
least healthy bar in the UK is the big
taste toffee whole nut bar one of these
contains 560 calories per 100 grams a
slight increase on Dairy Milk but what
is the least healthy chocolate bar here
in India
it's the dairy milk silk hazelnut 100
grams of this contains 571 calories
which is more than any bar in the UK I
guess it's a win I'm counting it as a
win anyways I'm going to go on a long
run because I definitely have diabetes
at this point thank you for watching
make sure to subscribe to the channel
it pays for my hospital bills